dr vivek dallas will be enlightening us
for this knowledge on role of
bioinformatics in the present era of
high throughput biology digital health
and drug discovery
and let me introduce dr gravey
he was born and raised in india in the
city of joy kolkata vivek das doctor has
been quite the wanderer having lived in
various parts of the country and the
world from having a bachelor's degree in
bio technology from bangalore university
masters in biomedics from bit mestra
ranchi ig programmer analyst job he did
in cognizant kolkata he holds a phd i
reports talking cancer computational
biology from ieo milan an industrial
postdoc at novo nordisk seattle
dr vivek's professional career has a
global footprint presently a doctor
provides fashion brought him to denmark
where he is the computational biology
senior research scientist at
bioinformatics and data mining
department and nominated
so what is bioinformatics in the time of
high throughput biology
now modern medicine and biology has gone
a tremendous improvement and evolution i
would say it's a revolution
in current age where we have so much of
high throughput you know technologies
where we can measure
different modalities uh from you know we
can do imaging we can understand tissues
composition we can do genotyping we can
actually also leverage the powerful
omics like genomics transcriptomics
proteomics
not only from organs but our tissues or
cells but also in vitro settings or in
vivo settings all these taken together
when we sequence them we can actually
build up a map or network
at a cellular level right and these when
put into sequencing machines can
actually build a huge information
complex or multi-omics
information that can help us to tease
out the different molecular uh features
which can help which when integrated
properly can help us to understand the
disease progression of the or the kind
of disease drivers
so there's a lot of scope of research
out there and bioinformatics has to you
know play a lot of role in this
now here what i'm trying to say is apart
from the work i do as a part of the
scientist
for the company i work for neurologists
i also sometimes you know do work with
certain students back in india
where i you know put my brains in some
curiosity
projects
and as a part of these project projects
i think about problems
in method development for bulk multimix
integration as you can see here on the
available method
so here i am now progressing to the end
part of my slide the last slides are
future state of aspirin and aspirations
of modern medicine
i see that medicine is actually
going interdisciplinary in terms of
cell-based intercepting
why because now we have
a huge explosion of you know single cell
data
and single-celled multi-year mix of
single data means a lot of uh you know
advanced statistical and machine
learning methods because the data
dimension is huge
and and this also means we are also
getting better at understanding
orthogonal you know experimental disease
markets but this is great future for us
because now we are trying to go in a
high dimensional era of medicine where
we are trying to understand the disease
trajectory from healthy to different
type of disease being neurological
cancer or you know
chronic but we can actually understand
one cell at a time how the disease is
evolving and we can actually detect
early which can actually understand this
uh the molecular mechanisms and actually
you know get better new drug targets and
these are these can all happen if we can
efficiently use bioinformatics
so here i come to my last slide
uh i hope i was able to convey how
bioinformatics is actually you know
helping the modern medicine and
biology
all these informations that we are
trying to accrue these days using
molecular spatial molecular astrological
analytical
this is uh a huge abundance of data
these are
you know high dimensional data
but the overall goal is to
take all these different modalities of
players together
build up integrated you know cell
phenotypic map that can be multi-scale
multimodal
which can actually help us to understand
the
underlying phenotype of the cell
and when we understand the phenotype the
cell we can better understand the states
that can be the you know epigenomic
states the cellular interaction the
tissue organization
you know and the identification of some
sometimes news or the cell type which
eventually can help us to understand
disease mechanisms interactions you know
signatures and new biomarkers
all and
overall can help in designing leaner
clinical trials
which can improve personalized medicine
and eventually also will help us
building
you know better improved drugs
so this is how i see the field of
bioinformatics contributing to the
modern medicine
and i hope
i was able to
share some of the thoughts with you all
[Music]